يتم تعريف حفلة الشواء في تكساس من خلال
مفاصل الشواء الريفية التي
تذهب إلى مكان مثل مطعم غولدي ، نعم ، إنه
يحتوي على عنوان يستحق الحصن ولكنه
بعيد عن قلعة وسط المدينة
عندما تخرج إلى هنا ، ستكون مثل
هذا التوجه للأمام
[موسيقى
]  القيام بزيارات كهذه
للاستمتاع بشيء قد يكون
أجنبيًا قليلاً مثل البقاء في
طابور طويل لتناول اللحوم المدخنة
،
أشعر حقًا وكأنها مناسبة خاصة
أنا دانيال فون ، أنا محرر الشواء
في تكساس شهريًا
كل أربع سنوات نذهب  حولنا ونأكل
أكبر قدر ممكن من الشواء في جميع أنحاء
الولاية ونتوصل إلى ما نعتقد أنه
أفضل 50 مفصل شواء ، كانت صدمة كبيرة
أن Goldie كانت رقم واحد
افتتحت في فبراير من عام 2020 في ذلك العام
كانت صعبة خاصة الركض على جانب الرصيف
مع خدمات الوزن ،
يكون الأمر صعبًا للغاية لأنه لم يكن هناك
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يحبون الخروج لتناول الطعام في
المطاعم ، لكننا كنا نتقاضى مثل 50
سنتًا من الراتب يوميًا
لمواصلة تحقيق ذلك ، والآن أحب
البطانة الفضية لها كما لو أننا
الجزء الأول مما أعتقد أنه مميز في
Goldie هو أنهم لا يحاولون
إعادة اختراع كل شيء ولكنهم ما زالوا
يجدون طريقة للحصول على عناصر التوقيع الخاصة بهم
بالطريقة التي يقومون بها بأضلاعهم الاحتياطية
إنه فريد حقًا ، فهم يصنعون أساسًا
شرابًا بسيطًا من الخل والسكر
ويستخدمون ذلك نظرًا لأن طبقة التزجيج الخاصة بهم رقيقة
بما يكفي بحيث لا تحصل على مثل هذا
الطلاء الثقيل السميك الحلو ، لكنه رقيق بدرجة
كافية بحيث تحصل على القليل من
هذه الحلاوة في  يقوم كل شخص في
العديد من مفاصل الشواء في تكساس بطهي مجموعة كبيرة
من الشواء طوال الليل ،
هذا هو الشواء المتاح لهم
لهذا اليوم وعندما
يفتحون هدفهم هو محاولة بيع هذا
الشواء بأسرع ما يمكن
يريدون تقديمه على أنه طازج  بقدر ما يستطيعون
ولا يريدون أن يكون لديهم بقايا طعام ،
لذا ستقف في طابور ،
لقد وصلنا هنا الساعة الرابعة ، أعني
أننا الأوائل هنا ،
قلت آه ، أنت متأكد من أننا يجب أن نذهب إلى
ذلك مبكرًا.  قال نعم
يا رجل نحن أولا  تماشيًا
مع من هو الأحمق الآن ،
سيظهر الأشخاص في الساعة 3 صباحًا قبل أن
تبدأ الخدمة فقط للانتظار في الطابور ، إنها تقريبًا
مثل طائفة لا تراها في
كل
مكان تقابل فيه أشخاصًا جددًا ، وتكوين صداقات جديدة ،
إنها ثقافة في حد ذاتها
تشعر وكأنها  لقد بذلت العمل للحصول على
الشواء الخاص بك ،
كيف تسير الأمور إلى
أين أنت قادم من
رائع
، حاول التحدث إلى كل عميل
ومنحهم تجربة رائعة ، إنه مجرد
لحم صدر ونقانق لكم اليوم ،
حسنًا ، شكرًا لكم جميعًا  الكثير للخروج
إذا كنت من خارج الولاية أو
خارجها ، مثل جعلها تجربة
ارتداء بعض أحذية رعاة البقر وشرب بعض البيرة ،
وأعتقد أن البيرة المجانية رائعة مثل
شكرًا لك على الانتظار ،
لقد بدأنا مبكرًا لذلك  الطريقة
التي يمكنك من خلالها أن تكون قادرًا على
قيادة الشواء إلى المنزل في وقت لاحق عندما
يحصلون بالفعل على نفسه
[موسيقى]
معظم أفضل 50 بحثًا عندما يتعلق
الأمر بتخفيضها إلى 50 بحثًا ، فالأمر كله
يتعلق بالعثور على الأخطاء وفي
جولديز هم  فقط لم ينجحوا وكان
هذا ما كان عليه  المذهل
عنهم كان المكان الذي أعطانا مرارًا وتكرارًا
صينية مثالية من الشواء ،
هذا أفضل ما تناولته على الإطلاق ،
لا أبالغ في
أننا نريد فتح مطعم
معنا فقط مع أصدقائنا الذين تعرفهم طهي
الطعام و  رؤية الناس سعداء ويعملون
بجد وقد اتضح أن
هذا أمر رائع بالنسبة لنا
[تصفيق]